- Hey guys, it's Justine,
and we are at the Samsung
Galaxy Unpacked event
and guess what we have here?
This is the Samsung Galaxy Z Flip.
They announced this before
the event even happened
and they aired a commercial at the Oscars,
which was kind of incredible
because there were rumors,
but the Oscars commercial
just confirmed it.
And here it is, it's in my hands.
(gentle music)
So this is the Z Flip.
It has a 6.7-inch AMOLED
Infinity Flex display
with a 1.1-inch AMOLED
display on the front.
When you double-tap on the power button,
which also is a fingerprint sensor,
this will activate the selfie camera,
so you can take a selfie.
Look at that!
It also has wireless charging,
but it isn't 5G compatible
with the rest of the S20s.
It's running a Snapdragon 855 Plus.
It has eight gigs of
RAM, 256 gigs of storage,
and 3300 milliamp dual battery.
There's two 12 megapixel
cameras in the back.
There's a wide angle
and an ultra-wide angle
and on the inside, of course,
it has a selfie camera,
and that's 10 megapixels.
It comes in three different colors.
There's mirror purple, black,
and gold in some markets.
They also have one other version.
This is the Thom Browne edition.
This one is a limited edition version
and they are launching it
at New York Fashion Week.
So I only get a few
minutes with this thing,
but what the crazy part about this
is this is being released
on Valentine's Day,
so what a treat to us.
You can get it at various retailers and
the fact that this is
being launched so soon
without pre-orders or
anything was kind of shocking.
When I saw that flash up on the screen,
I was like, "wait a minute,
that's just a few days away."
So my initial impressions
is it doesn't feel cheap
like I feel like one of the things that
when you have a flip phone like this
I never really had much time
with the Samsung Galaxy Fold
but one of the things I like about this is
this feels substantial,
like when this is in my hand, like,
it feels nice.
Let me do a pocket test.
This isn't a real pocket!
What kind of lie is this?
- [Jenna] You want to put it in my pocket?
- Do you have a pocket?
- I have a pocket.
- [Justine] In Jenna's pocket,
'cause I don't have one.
That's nice.
Oh, flex.
That's cool.
Give me that back!
So what's cool about this
is different applications
will change depending upon
how you have the phone.
So right now we have the full screen mode,
we're watching YouTube,
but if we fold this,
the video will continue to play up top,
but down below you have all
of your YouTube comments
and you can basically interact with this
like a little tiny laptop.
It's so cute!
You can also do full screen mode.
Ta-da!
So one of the things I
really like is this hinge.
It's really stiff so if you
were to place this somewhere,
it can basically kind of
act as a little tripod.
They did a little demo
at the Keynote where
you can take a selfie or
you can do Google Duo calls.
I like this because it doesn't feel
like it's just gonna shut on it's own
and speaking of closing it.
You have over 200,000 folds, they say.
You can tell that there is
a little bit of a crease,
but this doesn't feel like plastic
because it's actually a
very, very ultra-thin glass.
Do you see me?
Do you see it?
I just took our picture
using the front flip.
How cool!
So this is just my first look
at the Samsung Galaxy Z Flip.
This is pretty cool.
I love the future thoughts of
the integration of having
foldable phones like this
because taking something that is this big,
folding it in half, and
it is now half the size,
I am definitely really into that.
I was gonna say that I wish I
could do that with my laptop,
but technically that's kind
of what you're already doing.
Well, see you guys later.
I'll have some more
videos coming out soon.
So make sure you like,
comment, and subscribe!
Make sure to hit the bell
and I will see you in my next video.
Jenna, your turn.
- [Jenna] Thank you!
- Oh, I need a thumbnail!
- Did you see what colors it comes in?
- Yeah, in the VO.
(slow electronic music)